On est d'accords Michel, t'évites les sujets qui fâchent...?
C'est Noël ! Et pour une fois qu'on a tout le monde à la maison !
Tout le monde, c'est bien ça le problème...
En plus Marjorie à dit qu'elle voulait nous présenter quelqu'un !
Ouais ben si elle nous ramène le même genre d'énergumène que ses sœurs,
on est pas dans la panade.
Salut tout le monde, je vous présente Ugluk !
Bonjour !
Un orque...!
Pourquoi pas un troll ou un gobelin...?
Oui mais vas pas lui donner des idées toi !
*rôt*
Il sera là Karl Lagerfeld ?
Il sera là Shrek ?
Il sera là Grincheux ?
Ils arrivent en carriole ou quoi ?
Et s'ils sont des vannes sur les nains, je fais quoi ?
Et bah tu rigoles, tu fais le jovial !
Ouais, je fais le nain quoi ...
Hahahaha...!
On a gardé le ticket, si vous voulez l'échanger...
En même temps on pouvait pas savoir que vous étiez...
...grand !
Oui voilà ! Grand.
Un elfe, un nain, et maintenant un orque ! Pour vos parents c'est la Désolation de Smaug, non ?
Haaahaaahaaa...
Je peux toucher vos oreilles ?
Un peu racistes tes parents, non ?
C'est... C'est de l'humour.
En tout cas, ils vont nous faire une jolie confrérie...
*Pleure*
Enfin, c'est ce qu'ils disent quoi...